hey guys what's up I'm Alana and welcome
to my channel today we're going another
Q&A feigning 85,000 subscribers thank
you all so so much it's crazy and uh
thank you to everyone who submitted
questions they're all like really nice
even though you had the barrier of
anonymous some people will like how are
you fine but that said I'm not censoring
any questions from this the only
questions that I'm not answering
questions that I've answered in other
videos all the things that I don't have
an interesting answer to which is
questions like if you could visit any
country which would it be its Belgium I
just don't think that it's a very
interesting answer oh we did get a lot
of sexual stuff so brace yourselves
would you consider yourself to be good
in bed if you know what I mean yes I can
sleep for days seriously you are asking
me that one what question would you like
to never hear / answer again uh probably
the most annoying question that I ever
get asked is if I like tell someone
interests in passing about an Internet
comment with someone said they wanted to
Mota me or I get sent a dick pic or
someone says they want to rape me people
will always ask why did they say that
and I hate that question because it
sounds like it's blaming me for the
person who did that like usually I've
never spoken to them I don't know them
at all there is no reason that I could
possibly know do you think DJing has
changed what battle all was of the
possibility is with the addition of
computers and new electronics I really
hate DJ pretentiousness I think that
there are a lot of different styles of
DJing and I think it's it's cool there
are some people who don't manually beat
match that you suck would do that and a
lot of the DJing community hates that I
think it's fine I think kind of
arguments about like what real DJing is
it's silly and people should be allowed
to perform however they want as long as
they understand key they understand what
something go together and they can get a
crowd excited and perform well then I
think it's cool if you want to use for
iPads and a mixer to do that that's fine
with me I don't think it's better or
worse I think it's just people using the
technology differently but the only
boring question that I am going to
answer
cuz I got it so many times was something
along the lines of would you move to
America full-time if given the chance
and I should clarify that I basically
have I'm my visa last three years I'm
definitely going to be at the three
years it's very likely that I will bring
you my visa at the end of that period of
time unless I get a job somewhere else I
am an American full time right now that
said I think Australia is a much better
country to live in and I don't want to
live in America until I die I want a
great job at IGN so far especially I'm
beyond yeah
what's one thing you worry about that
keeps you up at night uh speaking of
beyond Brian who I work with at IGN he's
also on that podcast I hope he doesn't
mind me saying this but his mom recently
got diagnosed with a fairly serious
stage of cancer and that really affected
me not just for someone who's being
friends with Brian but the idea that I'm
so far away from my family and one of
them we could get sick tomorrow really
bothers me it was something that was
really hard before I left Australia as
well knowing that every time I see my
family now which might be once a year it
could end up being less than that in the
long run because it's so expensive I
think that they will probably have
noticeably aged whereas when I was
living in the same country as them that
obviously wasn't a problem I hate that I
hate knowing that my family is all
healthy right now and I am not with them
I'm in a completely different country
really far away that will never get
easier I don't think are you afraid to
try anything there's a lot of stuff that
I would not eat we need a frog I
wouldn't eat like a testicle no way you
could get me to eat a scorpion or a
spider I've also never done drugs what
does a guy have to do to get a date with
you I know this is creepy Oscar no me
internet or whatever please answer
honestly even if it's just so we can
find out how to ask other girls like you
out and stand a chance
for me to say yes to a date with a guy I
basically have to have blatantly
initiated it if a guy on the street
awesome on a date I would absolutely say
no there is no way that I would ever go
on a date with someone that I hadn't
spoken to at length prior I believe that
by virtue of being a woman you'll
automatically qualified to talk about
feminist issues this is a really
interesting question actually um no I've
actually like been interviews where
people ask me questions about feminism
and female representation in media and
my thing is always like look I don't
know I haven't studied it I just really
like video games I have no idea it's the
same as when I tweeted a thing about
people who send me rape threats I
started screenshotting them and sending
them to their parents on Facebook I
would track them down and do that if
people just kept asking me about
bullying and why kids bully and how to
avoid bullying it's like look this is
just a thing that I did I'm not an
expert on bullying or on Facebook
suddenly this is very strange that
people consider me an expert because
it's something that I did it's strange
what's your opinion on [ __ ] cosplayers
like girls who just seem to dress up for
attention and not because they even know
the character I don't think it's hurting
anyone at all totally fine good I think
that no matter what cosplay is always
meant to be for fun so as long as you're
having fun and you know that's it as
long as you're enjoying yourself I don't
care why you do it I don't care if it's
for attention I also don't think that
people were aware of revealing costumes
are necessarily doing it for attention
they could just be sexually expressive
people they could just feel comfortable
that way it could just be more fun for
them do you believe in God
no I do have moments in my family and I
went to a Catholic Primary School but I
don't believe in God though I would
consider myself to be very educated on
the Bible I elipse real please answer
looks like injections yes my lips are
real actually when I was younger people
used to comment on what nobody hasn't a
really long
I know when I was like 12 or 13 people
would kind of make fun of my lips in a
weird way but that hasn't happened since
then really at all maybe they looked
overly large for someone who was young
in your personal opinion what was the
thing you consider helped you the most
to make an impact buying the Australian
gaming community so big that it gave you
the opportunity to come to USA I made
myself very well-rounded
I was published in magazines I was
published on websites I worked in radio
for four years I was on TV and I had a
YouTube channel so it was literally just
that I covered all of the bases a lot of
people just focus on video or just focus
on writing and yeah I made an effort to
do all of the things how do you DJ Wells
you book for private / public parties
this is a very strange place to ask this
question but sure on that night though
people keep asking me to DJ in that city
for like Oswin I'm coming to that city
to DJ it's not that easy I'm still
Philly on the hood / as a DJ because
that's not my main source of income so I
don't know any clubs in the u.s. so it's
not like I can just do that like I mean
I can't afford to fly to your city rent
a venue rent a hotel and DJ there it's
not going to happen I think this is the
dirtiest question I got which is how
often do you masturbate like write it in
a diary who who counts that dear diary
today I masturbated sincerely a lot of
no what can I hug oh you'll probably
physically capable of hugging but hug me
unless it's from a family member or
someone I'm dating or someone that I'm
very close to
I don't really hug people the only
exception is when someone says something
very sweet I'm very bad at responding to
compliments they make me very
uncomfortable I don't like them at all
so my reaction instead of having the
same thing is usually to hug only when
it's my way of getting out of woods if
you had to live on a deserted island for
the rest of forever with one of two
terrible men and poking gold fob and
sleep up here who would it be but those
who don't know Golf Club and sleeve uh
two people that I work with at a GN
probably my two best friends in America
and we're on podcast together I would
probably say I think I would choose
Andrew because I feel like Mahdi would
die I'm like I'd have like a week and
then he would have an allergy to
something and died so I would just be
alone on the island with dead body it
would be like that movie with Daniel
Radcliffe or it's just like a fighting
corpse how fat the [ __ ] though look I'm
gonna be honest I don't know what that
means what was your first tattoo my
first tattoo was the Batman logo on the
back of my neck I got it when I was 17
in my boyfriend at the Times kitchen it
was like a humdrum tattoo but it's
honestly probably one of my better
tattoos I think the one that's best done
is this Totoro I'm not gonna show you
that man because that's annoying
but yeah it's like basically looks like
a Batarang what would you say is your
biggest weakness puppies no seriously I
have a little illness it's a really bad
allergies I have really bad asthma I
have a back problem I have an ankle
problem I have a knee problem I sleep a
lot and I'm just basically despite going
to the gym every day and eating
incredibly healthy I'm a very poor King
human is it thank you for all the
questions everyone you are all very
polite and I really appreciate it and
thank you so much for 85,000 subscribers
those incredible my channel is actually
growing really really slowly probably
because I don't upload videos enough and
I don't like jump on hide stuff like I'm
not gonna upload Call of Duty montages
or the grant that photo funny moments or
anything like that so a special thank
you to everyone who has subscribed and
stayed subscribed
or the three years that I've had my
channel I post a lot of different stuff
and I appreciate you sticking with me on
that Johnny it's awesome you're all
great people and I will see you next
time